foreign
hi good afternoon everyone
thank you for taking uh time to
uh to spend with us uh
in this uh live session um
our topic today is on after cellular
carcinoma
and i will be uh
briefly giving you the background of the
of the
disease and then i would be privileged
in introducing the panelists uh
we are due to some technical issues
we were we are only having two of our
st experts on this panel today
and after that we would go to the uh
questions where uh there will be
uh questions directed to each of the
panelists and also to the
uh group so they can uh help us
understand more
on this disease state so let's
start as we know hepatocellular
carcinoma is one of the most prevalent
cancers
and leading causes of related death
globally
in contrast to the declining death rates
observed for all other common cancers
such as breast lung and prostate cancers
the death rates for alola carcinoma
continue to increase
by two to three percent per year because
hepatocellular carcinoma is frequently
diagnosed
late and is no curative therapy
for an advanced hepatocellular carcinoma
the early diagnosis of hepatocellular
carcinoma
is truly a big challenge and i know our
panelists will agree with this
at risk individuals are advised to
undergo
periodic hepatocellular customer
screening
if identified at an early state
surgical section offers a favorable
prognosis
with a five-year survival rate of more
than 70
the lack of surveillance and
insufficient early diagnostic position
are blamed for the poor prognosis
and high mortality of the hepatocellular
carcinoma
over the past years the early diagnosis
of hepatic cellular carcinoma
has relied on surveillance with
ultrasonography
and serological assessments of alpha
fetal protein
in this panel discussion we are going to
talk on early
and very early diagnosis of
hepatocellular carcinoma
and the utility of new biomarkers
and various model for better assessment
of at risk patients
ladies and gentlemen we are here
privileged to have
two esteemed experts for this panel
discussion today
let me introduce them to you and
i would request each of the panelists
to briefly introduce themselves
of their expert expertise
to the audience first
ladies comes first right i would
like to introduce dr labio
the former president hepatology society
of
and hepatologists of the makati medical
center
in manila and our second
panelist is dr pian rao
president of indian national association
for the study of liver and
chief of hepatology and nutrition
in the asian institute of gastro
gastroenterology
i now request dr labio to briefly
tell us about herself so that we would
understand
more and after that dr bienro
yeah good afternoon everyone and thank
you dr vega for that introduction
and i'd like to thank the organizers for
the invitation
for today's apple summit
and it is really a indeed a privilege to
be
joining the paddle with dr rao today
this afternoon to talk about
a very very relevant topic for this
afternoon which is on liver cancer
i am a hepatologist from the makati
medical center
and it is my pleasure to be talking to
you
this afternoon about liver cancer thank
you dr
jada
thank you dr labview
thank you and then all the people
welcome to this
very important session i am dr p.m raw
i'm a hepatologist at the asian
institute of gastroenterology in
hyderabad which is in the central
india and i feel that it is a
very very apt that we are discussing
here this topic today
because as already been emphasized we
are paying to see the patients coming
late in fact majority of our patients in
india
even here they come quite late you know
when you have to give
only the chemotherapy at that stage they
come
and in that point of view and this
appears to be an extremely
relevant you know for us has already
been emphasized
that a very early diagnosis is it goes
without saying
uh over to jaga thank you dr
bell now uh
very kind of our panelists introduce
themselves and the expertise and
we know how valuable they are for this
particular
uh discussion um
if i may i would like to proceed with
the
questions to the panelists
who are here and also help us
cover the few questions that we have
prepared for the other other two
panelists who couldn't attend our
session today
please give a brief
on the tools tests that you
that you utilize in your institution for
early diagnosis
and management of hepatocellular
carcinoma
and your opinion on the same dr
labio yeah so i'm coming from the
philippines
where um we are a country where um
liver cancer is the fourth most common
cause of cancer and
actually is the second cause of cancer
death
in my country it's it's not surprising
because hepatitis b
is hyper endemic in our country
um where 16 of filipino adults
have chronic hepatitis b infection so we
actually
follow most professional society
guidelines
for htc surveillance which is
the combination of ultrasound and afp
every six months for patients at risk
so once we see a mass on ultrasound even
in a patient with
a normal afd we proceed
straight away with a contrast ct scan
and mr mri at least in my practice
so but however in recent years we
have been realizing that both
the standard surveillance tests
ultrasound and efp
are imperfect tests so we have been
realizing
its limitations in our daily practice
so i'm sure dr rao will share his
experiences
with us as well that we are increasingly
realizing the limitations of these tests
so now we
we are increasingly using other tests
so such as other biomarkers in
combination with
ultrasound and afp in certain situations
where
where we think ultrasound the
performance of
ultrasound are is hampered so there are
certain patient characteristics
where we think the quality of the
ultrasound
is um is inadequate for example
in patients with ascites or in patients
with advanced liver disease for example
where we see a nodular liver
or for example in patients with nash
or in patients with increased bmi so
perhaps it is in these situations where
we see
low quality ultrasound so
um we are also using
these biomarkers in situations that are
beyond
diagnosis and surveillance for example
in monitoring response to treatment
um so we're slowly
expanding um testing not
just with ultrasound and afp but also
exploring
other biomarkers other tests other than
the standard
ultrasound and afp so um
that's it so thank you dr rao
oh yeah you made my job very simple
because uh you know that we all been
following these standard guidelines you
know what
what but uh what brings us to see
that you know they come into very late
advanced stages
that means that we have in
we are all internationally centers right
you know
so we have everything is there but our
job is to educate
that down below the people the
physicians
and the clinicians who are taking care
of them
that has not gone you know in general
perhaps across the
world you know this one and when the
patient comes to you
surveillance is not a great job right
when the patient comes to you to the
tertiary centers
and then you naturally you will follow
him up according to the guidelines
either three months or six months
whatever is the form
of we know that the ultrasound is
dependent upon the observer dependent
and many times we feel that you know
when ultrasound is
even in the institutions when it is done
ultrasound
does not pick up some of the things
because of the tissue characteristics of
the then we've been helped by the afp
alpha feta protein although in the west
in the asld guidelines you know they
don't believe the fb
alone and ap under ultrasound
and what is more important for
for us is that a serial changes in the
alpha feta protein longitudinal change
is an extremely important one in the
surveillance program
even a minor increases of even 10
milligram increase
10 energy increase also means something
and also here we are stuck with
sometimes you know
an incidentally detected hepatocellular
carcinoma it's not unusual
we had had about really represented
sometime in ascre
and they are they are very aggressive
tumors they are incidentally detected
patient goes for an ultrasound and there
is a large
and infiltrative lesion of course there
we cannot do anything you know
but our main thing is to educate the
down
below you know of course we have our own
limitations uh
so far we've been relying on ultrasound
and alpha feta protein we know the
limitations of the alpha beta protein
after late we started doing the
eukaryote
that is the pcp right we run about 200
patients
now we're in the process of analyzing
but
it has certainly but we have not
combined and then seen as now because as
a gallaudet model
say so that is have to be done but
certainly
in the people about really about 20-25
of these patients will be negative for
an alpha beta protein
in that group we have been benefited
by the dcp
this has been our uh my overall
experience here but otherwise we follow
the standard guidelines that
you look at the main main problem comes
the differentiation between the
quarantine carcinoma
and alpha and hepatocellular carcinoma
especially when they are small when they
become big
of course you know characterizes itself
but they are small
is very difficult to diagnose and that's
where we need
some more help and early diagnosis
thank you i mean um i've got two
questions from what
i've just understood from both of y'all
it's very clear
that this particular disease is always
seen at the later stages uh and
um and uh to to a certain
extent uh there is uh there has been a
lack of
modalities for early diagnosis my
question here is
how do you think we can overcome this
is it through uh awareness program for
the the patient group or the physicians
uh what more can be done so that the
awareness of
this particular uh disease uh
state could be um to the people
dr rao yeah i i think
you have hit on the nail about what i
have been
thinking i always felt that sitting in
these
towers right you know doing the
surveillances
is also okay and then even the even here
we have issues
even the patient who is coming
constantly if he misses
one follow-up right and sometimes you
know you feel that
especially in the covet area this plane
when the lockdown has
happened the person who was supposed to
for me has missed about a one
and then then we find that there is a
small trooper already there
so my thing is that the education has to
go
to the practicing across basically all
the groups
even the medical students are also you
know the the emphasis has not been
so much about these you know and mainly
we have to
address the physician groups right
and the basic post mbbs post
md and
by taking the local associations and
then this and the message has to go you
know
beyond ours beyond the uh the
centers you know where they have been
because because the centers
see those people who can afford to come
to the place
what about the people who cannot afford
to come to these
the tertiary centers so we have to go
through the different societies you know
the medical association societies of the
clinicians
and the practitioners and perhaps even
with this kind of a platforms nowadays
you know where you don't require the
physical presence
i think we should be able to cut across
the various groups
with a relative ease and then make our
point very clear
over
thank you dr uh dr labia would you like
to add anything
on this one i couldn't agree
more with dr rao i think there was this
interesting study that showed even among
specialists
um there was only a 15 adherence
to to to surveillance guidelines so even
if the surveillance guidelines are out
there that we should do
ultrasound and af plus or minus afp
every six months i mean that is pretty
disappointing
that only 50 of specialists are
actually following these surveillance
guidelines so we
we really need to do a lot of work even
among ourselves so i'd agree with dr
rao there that we need to do a lot of
work
uh on awareness
i'm i'm a kind of person who's very
interested in
having continuous medical education um
and during my uh even my med school days
and even
practicing as a physician
topics were only related around
the fast moving things like antibiotics
and
so blah blah blah we never had serious
discussion on
everything about hepatocellular
carcinoma now we need people like you
to help us drive to create this
awareness
after this this session um we should
reach out and get together
and see how we can create the awareness
among not only among the physicians
but also among the public where they
need to have
uh to have a consideration of having
regular checkup and uh and follow up and
so on
now do you all agree with that that we
should proceed in this
way and so on uh
yes of course you know i mean can't
disagree anymore
but the thing is that we have to
of course initially concentrate upon the
high risk groups
that is who our hepatitis b and then
hepatitis c
especially after the development of a
cirrhosis
we have to emphasize to the clinicians
who are following up afterwards and also
to the public and the patients that
simply reducing the levels of a dna or
achieving an spr in these patients after
the development of sclerosis
is not enough they are under the radar
for surveillance for hepatocellular
carcinoma
in fact we should be more careful among
them
than those people who did not have any
sugar
and thirdly and nash is coming up as you
know that one you know nationally
related carcinoma is coming up with a
big
way uh i mean one reason we know that
the obesity
and the diabetes you know the term
diabetes
is also used for this condition you know
that
diabetes and obesity independently have
got a higher risk for malignancy
not only in hepatosphere area in all the
rest of the areas
so the a person who is a diabetic and
an obese person with
a fatty liver and with hepatitis b
or c one can imagine that the chances of
getting the hepatitis c
very high so the it is not only that we
go for hepatitis b
and c and also we must work with the
laptop as a central analysis
now they're also very much interested in
this nafld
now
thank you dr rao dr labio
yeah i think dr dr jega you said you
highlighted it
very well in your introduction i think
that was an eye opener when you said
that
all other cancer rates cancer rates are
declining
or the survival rates for other cancer
are improving and yet
we still see fat very poor five-year
survival rates for liver cancer
i think that in itself is an eye opener
for the public
for us to drive awareness why that is so
and i think that is because through all
these years we have not yet
learned that ultrasound is not enough
as a standalone surveillance test
i think we need to do more in terms of
detecting
early i mean in detecting hcc earlier
and better and actually even predict
future hcc and what's sad about
the entire thing is that we already know
that liver cancer occurs exclusively
in those people with chronic liver
disease so
we actually have a target population
that we can actually focus our
surveillance
efforts on and yet we could not
nip it in the butt so that tells us that
there is we need to do something more
in terms of adding on to that
surveillance test that we are already
using
so maybe ultrasound plus afp plus
something else
right so so what we're doing and the
rate that we are doing it
is not enough so we need to do more
so we need to do it more often or we
need to do it better
so if that way we can catch it earlier
diagnose
it early apply curative therapies
because even if we have curative
therapies available we can't apply them
because we're not detecting it early
enough like dr rao
said detected late same situation
in the philippines we get them bclcd
and c so even if we have the ability to
ablate
or resect we can't apply them because of
late diagnosis
so i think that is where we should focus
our efforts so so so webinars like this
focusing on early detection and
predicting
future htc even is really a critical
area of unmet need
in all of us working in hcc
thank you very much
[Music]
can i just say my slogan is today
beyond afp dot dot dot
for early diagnosis beyond afp
dot dot dot then it will attract the
attention i think you can use this
and give me the royalty also
yeah exactly good good motto good slogan
we'll keep it and you have helped us to
come up with a new slogan for the
company
no problem you're a fp thank you yeah dr
i have a question specifically for you
um
what are the current challenges in the
surveillance
and the diagnosis of hepatocellular
carcinoma
of high-risk patients how to
overcome these challenges and
what is in your opinion would be the
best method
this is your specific question thank you
okay um i think dr rao and myself have
mentioned the biggest
challenge which is late diagnosis
so i think um i think the idea in the
ideal setting
if we're able to find a test
or a combination of tests that can
detect hcc early or
can even predict future hcc
with a survival benefit and can do this
in a cost-effective manner and then our
problems are solved
i think but however unfortunately at the
present time
this test or this combination of tests
remains elusive
at the present time so um in the
meantime
what can we do so i think we need to
address
um we need to address beyond ultrasound
and beyond
i think i i have to agree with dr rao
there and explore
other biomarkers to improve
the quality of ultrasound or add on
better imaging and then other biomarkers
i think that is
that should be the future direction and
then address
the issue of awareness and access
and the uptake of clinicians i think in
i think the issue of awareness and
access to these new tests it's not
just a problem in the philippines but
also in many other places
where access awareness availability
and even uptake of clinicians because
compared to ultrasound and afp these are
readily available
surveillance tests these are widely
accepted by
phones and yet 50
of us just do it in actual
clinical practice so i think we need to
work on all these
to overcome these challenges um
back to you jacob dr rao
thank you dr dr rau would you like to
add some
um oh yeah oh yes
our issue is that the main challenge is
that
we relatively are completely you must
be the asymptomatic nature of this book
they don't have any symptoms and
actually by the time they develop the
symptoms that a weight loss
and then lack of appetite mostly we
found that you know
weight unexplained weight loss is number
one and
of course update these are two standards
for any kind of a malignancy
but the persons who have got
asymptomatic are quite large they're
symptomatic and those people that means
anyone who is at a risk nowadays we are
doing the fibrous cancer
regularly in our patients anybody who
has gotten
advanced fibrosis need not have even a
cirrhosis also
advanced fibrosis and having cirrhosis
b and c has already told even if they've
achieved the
the desired things they have to be
in fact we write in our op ticket that
you know
ultrasound and afp especially for the
people of this process
every three to six months because
see in those countries where it is by
the insurance
and they like in usa or by the nhs or in
the countries where the
state has to clear the expenses
some of our places the patient himself
has who
has to bear and therefore we
tell them that you know you have to do
this wherever you are you know
i i mean it's it's clear here that we
[Music]
need to be very very uh
specially like maybe it has to be very
regimental
like how now they're having doing it for
kobe
uh you travel out of your district you
come back
uh you get your test done and you are
quarantined for two weeks
that's how i think things has to have to
be done for this
particular cases and then it has to be a
guideline i mean under guidelines and
have to be followed strictly
and i think if we achieve that
definitely we will bring down the
numbers
where we will increase the numbers of
early detection and uh
bring down the mortality numbers i i
suppose that's the only way we can do it
you know these world days you know
they have made a real good impact you
know especially
world hepatitis day right it's made a
good impact
and they're also of course
emphasizing this particular point i do
not know whether there is a
liver cancer day and is there any
cancer is we know what cancer day is
there you know
i think is a this month itself is this
one
but whether there is any hepatocellular
cancer
day i mean i'm just listening who is a
thought you know because we got a
days for everything and the impact of
those things
in the general public you know is really
this one although these is extremely you
may think there's a narrow area
but it is worth it especially with the
nash and then
alcohol and ash and then diabetes they
are going upwards
but something is a thought food for
thought
having a specific day for liver cancer
yeah that's
maybe that's one way we can also create
awareness among the people
yeah now dr rao my question to you
uh japanese society of hepatology
guidelines
are suggesting combination of various
tests for surveillance
what is your opinion on using pif
cartoon
and afp in combination for the
surveillance
in high risk group population as a first
test
we know that that the afp is itself is
not enough a
very significant number and at least 20
to 30 percent of the people with the
proven hypothyroid carcinoma they'll
have a
low levels of an afp so certainly there
is a need for
additional biomarkers you know for an
early diagnosis
and follow-up of these patients
but what i find is that individual
parameters
are not helpful it's been proven whether
it is
afp or whether it is a pivoca or whether
it is the afp l3
individual parameters have not been
helpful
putting together it is helpful
that means even afp and pivka
put together you may be able to do
something better than before
but it's still not ideal right
the ideal situation appears to be
of course the talk of nowadays hcc are
two things
the galad and then bella ii there are
two things
and liquid biopsy right
i mean the daily liquid biopsy of course
that is for the universal use
not only for hepatocellular carcinoma
for any cancers
but we it is still far away you know
meanwhile when we are here
uh i think you know the more
we have to emphasize upon the
gallant as you know that is being
validated across the world you know
maybe even the other three countries
germany
japan and then uk where it just started
and
that is still not very popular even in
the
guidelines even in the guidelines no do
not mention about
this one and i think
simply
may not be enough uh although at the
same time we are defeating the purpose
of a surveillance by increasing the cost
right the soundness one should be you
should not be very expensive
you should be very widely available any
biomarker
but we have our own limitations for this
one we can't go away with
uh without these things you know we
don't have any other number of
biomarkers have been
done you know at every level molecular
level biochemical level proteomics
but everything has been done but these
this these three have stood there
perhaps they are going to stand the test
of the time
yeah thank you dr rao um dr
i suppose you agree with uh dr rao
um and um i i've got
i've got a couple of questions more to
ask you all and
uh due to interest in time let me ask
you
questions where you answer yes or no
okay very simple
right doctor
pifka 2 is a better option over
afp for the recurrence monitoring after
surgical rejection
is it yes or no no combination is better
than
individual thank you
uh dr rao ultrasound is not sensitive
for
early detection it can be replaced by ct
scan
yes or no
um yes so you see the triphasic city
we have to emphasize that you know many
people are doing the conventional
city it's a dynamic city yes
okay uh doctors oh sorry
sorry yeah carry on no no no no no no go
go ahead go ahead nothing nothing
dr labio do you think detection at early
stage of hepatocellular carcinoma
is easy and effective with blood-based
biomarkers
yes or no
no it has to be in combination with
ultrasound
thank you dr rao the final question to
you
combination of biomarkers that is afp
and pif cartoon
is more sensitive than ultrasound as a
screening tool
yes or no
yes of course because that is not
because of the
richness or the greatness of these two
because of the limitation of ultrasound
yes
can we are we allowed to have uh
sure why not um
but i agree with you dr rao um yeah
at the present situation with what we
have
to both of you what would be your
suggestion
to move forward as
a screening tool for hepatocellular
carcinoma
with what we have right now
but we are not we are not looking at the
the best
because we don't have it but what we
have right now we have
ultrasound we have mri we have the
biomarkers such as efp
what would you think would be
cost effective
for for for as a screening tool
for all our high-risk patients both
of you i'll give it to dr lobby of us
okay um i think the data so far
has shown us that combination
combining the tests performs better
than the individual tests i think dr rao
has already mentioned that and i
think um with the galax score
i think the lessons to learn there is
that combining
certain clinical data so certain
demographic data is useful
combined with the biomarkers so i think
the future direction should be is that
we should be combining simple
clinical demographic data from our
patients
and then ideally combined with
inexpensive
blood-based biomarkers that are
accessible
okay that we can follow longitudinally
through time like dr rao was saying
earlier
long-decludingly through time um
and then of course in the era of
precision medicine
ideally this should be tailored for each
individual patient i think we should be
able to match this for each patient
and then predict predict future hcc
and i think not just detect early hcc
i think we should also be able to
predict
future hcc since we already know the
higher risk individual
and of course hopefully all these
efforts should translate
not just in improving survival i think
it should also translate into
not just cost effectiveness and
improving survival
but also good quality survival
i think i mean that would be a perfect
world
i think but that it's it's all
aspirational and i think that's
that's that's what we should aim for in
the future
i think dr jega you asked future
directions so i think
that is my aspirational and visionary
goal
back to you dr rao and dr jega
thank you dr labio yes doctor
yeah i think as of now what we are
having
is so far is only ultrasound and afp
across across the many places
and we clearly know that that itself is
not
enough right there is a need to add
another biomarker i am biomarker are
biomarkers
which has already been done and then
stood that validated across the is a
gallop model out of which
the two things are of course age and
then gender you know they are different
the three things like a lab and then
they are there
and if the ultrasound
and afp and pivka2
also have been shown to be better than a
either of afps and only single marker
although we
we we can have the third one i do not
know the logistics of uh doing it across
as as a surveillance test
for the gallon the gallon model in the
ballard model as you know that it's only
bilirubin and then argument performance
status
especially ii is a continuous model
rather than a static model
right uh i think the
the the the the feature
the proteomics and then all those things
are still theoretical and they are not
applicable
liquid biopsy is it far away to go as a
test
at this time we have to really bank upon
our biochemical
parameters like these three if we
have a s ultrasound and afp number one
ultrasound aop and pivoca are dc page
number two
ultrasound afp pivoca and dcp
and l3 is
and based on this one since the other
two are only this one you can calculate
this course of the gallery there are
sports
good thank you dr rao i've got one last
question before we
we closed off because due to uh time
constraint
uh to both of you all dr labio and dr
rao yeah
what is the activity of the asap model
which includes afp bifca2
age and sex in overall diagnosis of
hepatocellular carcinoma
and its benefit over the existing
approach
for diagnosing apertal cellular
carcinoma
dr labio okay
i think the asap model is a risk
calculator that was
really used to assess
the risk of developing hcc among
patients with predominantly
hpv hcc and since this model was
validated
richard population with hpv so it's
relevant in places where hdv is endemic
and where afp l3 is not
widely available
so it's useful in places like asia
pacific or the philippines
as well but like the galad we need to
build the evidence
base for its use number one
number two um we need to explore how we
can
use the asap model in combination
with ultrasound and in combination with
present elastography for example
perhaps that can improve early detection
rates
and improve the diagnostic performance
for not just early diagnosis but also
future prediction of hcc
thank you dr labio dr rao your comments
um uh the difference between
asap and the gallaudet is only absence
of l3 in asap model
isn't it and that's what i said earlier
only thing is that
what i said instead of age and sex which
are there in front of you i added
ultrasound
right afp and dcp i have added
and the on the ask model is a
calculation beyond
that one ultrasonic will be doing it and
then certainly i
i do not know i must ask you i am i'm
not very
familiar why is it difficult to do
l3 afp l3
uh why asp more asap model has come
why did they why someone has to remove l
three when gallaudet
is also being proposed is it difficult
to i'm not i'm not quite aware of
the technicalities of doing the afp l3
in the absence of that of course is the
best as you can say that the
asap model we have to follow in the
absence
yes the simpler the better for the
better
right but i think the acid model needs
to be validated in the non-hepatitis b
population
as well
especially now we see a lot of dash hcc
[Music]
so ultrasound underneath ultrasound afp
dcp they have been aware that
there are studies are there you know and
there are studies are definitely they
are
better there's no doubt about that and
adding another one is better
definitely we can see you know how the
asap
model goes and we have to examine why
l3 is so difficult
is it difficult to do it but why not add
that also and then make it true
so that was a good discussion both dr
labio and dr
rao very informative uh
we are here uh uh we're more
knowledgeable now
what more need to be done as
uh as a company now we realize that what
more we need to do from our side
and what we need to share with our
colleagues in the
medical fraternity and also to the uh
the public uh what needs to be done and
so on
um i would like to take this opportunity
to thank both of you all to
share your valuable time during this uh
difficult times uh sharing your thoughts
your expert opinions and and
and feedback and uh hope that
it will be useful to uh some of us uh
who are following up on this uh
uh virtual uh session
and uh i think there is more now this is
the i feel this is the connection for
as far as personally i am concerned that
for us to go beyond to look what more we
can do
to improve um
what we are facing right now um thank
you so much both of you all uh
it was great meeting you all uh as usual
we end a
session by saying stay safe and stay
healthy
right thank you
thank you very much bye-bye thank you